foreign
good morning
welcome to this meeting of the joytime
review and security committee I'm
councilor Keith wellerman and I'm
chairing the meeting today
I'll first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure that your mobile phones
and any other devices are on silent or
Switched Off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the model.gov app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where they are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to be
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
[Applause]
I'll just run through a list of
people who are attending
council's Jan Osborne here as is here as
baber District Council Cabinet member
for housing and will be introducing the
housing item
offices are Rebecca Ward housing
strategy and policy officer
AMA yantui yeboa Housing Solutions
corporate manager
Robert longfoot corporate manager tenant
services
we also have Jan Robinson corporate
manager of Law and governments and
Alicia Norman
to my left is the lead officer for
Overview at scrutiny and also we're
being assisted by Henriette Holloway and
Bethany Webb this morning
so can I move to the agenda please
item one is apologies for absence and
any substitutes please
thank you chair we we have apologies
from councilor Terence Carter with
councilor John Matheson substituting
this morning and we also have apologies
from councilor Robert Lindsay
thank you
are there any
Declarations of pecuniary or other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members please
there are none
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
to have we received any please none
received here thank you very much
so sorry
Mr chairman um I'm just thinking that uh
on the homes if I'm housing front where
they need to declare a non-pecuniary
interest as I am chairman of the midst
of a growth Limited
um well when shall we know that
um we'll know that
um but it's not an interest which means
that Council that peon can't speak isn't
it
you can speak and vote
thank you very much
right we're now going on to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 30th
of September
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes please
would anybody like to propose that we
accept
the minutes thank you councilor Caston
do we have a second to please counteract
meal
the governor's officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that is five votes for
and four abstentions that's Curry thank
you very much the minutes of the meeting
on the 30th of September 2022 have been
confirmed
are there any questions by the public
please
questions by counselors please
none received here thank you very much
we now move on to
the annual review update of the joint
homes and housing strategy and the
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy
2019-2024 this is item Jos 2217.
and I'd like to invite the cabinet
member for housing for baber to please
introduce the report to the committee
to introduce
consideration and scrutiny today the
annual update of the joint homes and
housing strategy and homelessness
reduction and rough sleeping strategy
2019 to 2024. in March 2019 members of
all political parties unanimously
approved the adoption of the first joint
homes and housing strategy and Joint
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy these strategies
commit us to be open and transparent
providing information on how we are
performing against the Strategic aims
set out within these documents so as
part of adoption a commitment was made
to report back to overview and scrutiny
committee for an annual review and
update to members
this is the third annual update of the
progress made against the strategies the
annual update this year includes a
presentation of a refreshed homes and
housing strategy the document is the
same as the 2019 version but the data
supporting documents and references have
been updated to ensure that only the
most recent and relevant information is
used in support of the vision and aims
of the strategy
the delivery plan has also been
refocused to include policy priorities
and emerging themes that weren't around
when the original strategy and delivery
plan plan was written in 2019
today I ask that members review the
contents of this report and appendices
along with verbal contributions scrutiny
should focus on the Strategic aims and
the progress with the delivery Rebecca
Ward our housing strategy and policy
officer who has responsibility for the
analysis of performance and monitoring
of this stuff strategy apologies
is with us today and will now provide
you with the presentation which shows
the progress to date and the future
actions planned thank you Mr chairman
thank you over to you Rebecca
right um good morning councilors
this presentation will provide you with
more detail and context around the joint
homes and housing strategy and a joint
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy we
um
is that better
um okay I'll start again then um this
presentation will provide you with more
detail and context around the joint
homes and housing strategy and the joint
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy we will be focusing on
what has been achieved
what has changed since the last time the
strategies came to overview in scrutiny
in September 2021
and what new actions officers will be
prioritizing in the coming year to
further our Collective progress towards
achieving the vision and the Strategic
aims of the strategies
foreign
okay so to start with some background
and context
The Joint homes and housing strategy and
the joint homelessness reduction and
rough sleeping strategy were both
adopted in March 2019.
and as we know the world has changed
significantly since then our new policy
priorities have emerged that were not
included in the original strategy
document and the delivery plan
the strategies had a lifespan of five
years from 2019 to 2024.
the strategy to reached the midpoint of
that lifespan in September 2021
and in August of 2021 cabinet members
and housing staff were briefed on the
proposal to relaunch The Joint homes and
housing strategy in 2022
work has been undertaken this year
under the steer of SLT and with the
awareness of portfolio holders to
refresh the joint homes and housing
strategy until we focus the associated
delivery plan
to ensure that they continue to be
relevant and focused on what actions we
can prioritize the best work towards
achieving the vision and the Strategic
aim of the strategies
I want to highlight here that the joint
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy is a separate document
to the Joint homes and housing strategy
however strategic aim three of the homes
and housing strategy which is
homelessness is prevented and our
services provide positive and planned
interventions
relates directly to the homelessness
reduction and rough scraping strategy
the statutory document and will be
formally reviewed and a new document
published in 2024
okay to move on to some figures around
the delivery plan
as of June 2020 there were 93 actions on
the delivery plan
following comments at last year's annual
review of The Joint homes and housing
strategy by the overview and scrutiny
committee
where it was noted that there was a
large number of actions with ongoing as
the target date
Streamlight streamlining exercise was
undertaken and as a result actions that
were considered to have become business
as usual and fully embedded within the
work of the teams have now been marked
as complete
as a result of this streamlining of the
93 actions on the delivery plan 52 have
been marked as complete
and 41 and the 41 remaining actions yet
to be completed have been transferred to
the newly refocused delivery plan
because what we know
thank you Mr chairman I I if we could go
back to that uh slide
I don't really understand these figures
uh the there are three figures that have
been transferred either from or to
something
I'm not sure what they mean and I'm not
sure that the comment you just made
about completed actions is consistent
with what we're seeing on on the chart
so I'd like a little bit more
explanation of
are we saying basically that effectively
there are 41 actions that are still
outstanding uh or not yeah that is what
we're saying so that's the total of the
35 actions that were in progress the two
that were in progress with minor delays
and the four that were yet to commence
those 41 have been transferred to the
new delivery plan
right
does that make sense yes and when are
they due to be completed
um they've all got individual Target
dates on them and I'll be talking about
those actions as we go through the the
presentation okay thank you thank you
okay so moving on
um so when we are talking about
refreshing the strategy document and
refocusing the delivery plan what has
actually changed well firstly and
importantly the vision and the nine
strategic aims of the joint homes and
housing strategy have not changed
they continue to be relevant and
reflective of The council's Wider
priorities so they have remained as they
are
the time frame has been removed and
replaced with a date published this is
to a better reflector the strategy is an
ever-evolving document rather than
having a fixed start and end point
all references to supporting documents
within the strategy document have been
updated where an update has been
available
to ensure that only the most current
supplementary information is referenced
likewise any references that have become
obsomely have been removed from the
strategy document
all data referenced within the strategy
has been updated where where more
current data is available
has been done to ensure that the
strategy is underpinned by the most
relevant and current supporting data
within the strategy document itself a
table has been added to the start of
each strategic game chapter
detailing what has been achieved what's
currently being worked on and what
actions will be targeted next
so moving on to the delivery plan which
is the living document working towards
the achievement of the vision and the
Strategic aims this document has been
thoroughly refocused to include the new
and emerging themes that were not around
when the delivery plan was originally
written back in 2019
41 actions that were on the previous
slide from the previous version of the
delivery plan have been transferred to
the new delivery plan and an additional
21 new actions have been added totaling
62 actions on the new delivery plan
the time scales and Target dates have
been tightened so that the document is
less vague and more targeted
however it's not been possible to
entirely avoid using ongoing as a Target
date for some of the actions
an additional column is being added to
the document detailing what success
would look like
this will Aid monitoring of the strategy
ensuring that there is Clarity over when
an action has been completed and enabled
us to better demonstrate the gains for
residents
document has been streamlined as already
outlined comments from the annual review
of the homes and housing strategy last
September and I'd say the archiving of
actions that become business as usual
and fully embedded in the work of the
teams
the delivery plan has also been
dovetailed with the outcomes framework
to ensure that we are clear which
strategy actions are contributing to
which outcomes
and I'll return to this later in the
presentation
also be noted here that there are two
versions of the delivery plan a public
version where there are no officer names
just job roles
and a member version that includes
officer names as action leads this is
the aid with accountability and access
for members but to avoid officer names
being in the public domain and this is a
result of comments that the ons chairs
briefing earlier this month
okay so I'm now going to move on to look
at each of the nine strategic AIMS in
turn to look at what has been achieved
what new actions have been added in the
refocus of the delivery plan and what
success will look like in the future
so starting with strategic aim one which
is the housing market functions
effectively providing homes which was
affordable as possible to meet the needs
of residents and support the local
economy
so in terms of achievements we have
published robust viability testing of
the joint local plan which gives
confidence that both infrastructure and
affordable housing needs can be met
we have improved our approach to
discharging planning conditions by
providing additional Clarity on the
information we require from developers
in order to discharge conditions
effectively
and we have encouraged and supported
self-built and custom build developers
by setting out positive policies in the
joint local plan
Rebecca can I just stop for just a
second before you go on to the next part
of the slide
okay thank you Jackson yeah I was
wondering are you I mean I haven't been
to scrutiny for quite a while are you
taking questions and and points as we go
along or or at the end or how are we
going to deal with that I have a point
on this slide so I wanted to
um ask when would you like questions uh
is it better at the end of the
presentation would be questions at the
end but I'm not sure how these things
normally
um yeah and then the points will come up
in debate after questions thank you
councilman young thank you Mr chairman
uh with due respect I don't think that's
a very good Way Forward
um anyone who's looked at this
presentation will see that there's a lot
of detail in pretty much every page of
this slide and to ask us to wait to the
end to recollect all the questions that
we might like to ask through them all is
not reasonable I don't think I think we
should while they're fresh in our minds
ask the questions as we move along thank
you would you be happy then to take
questions on each of the sides in turn
and then general questions at the end is
that while this slide is on
um when we finish when you finish
describing the slide I have questions on
the slide
and then we'll move on to the next slide
is everyone happy with that approach
thank you
can I hate you've got a question
councilor Mathis thank you yeah the on
the on the the achievements here did um
could you tell us the the degree of
success of um actually encouraging and
supporting self-build
Etc
um I mean I know we're
you know the joint local plan is is a
emerging document as we we say
how many houses have we actually managed
to get
um self-builder or custom built
um
you know thus far to State and
achievement
I wonder
could one of your colleagues look that
up while you continue with the
presentation
um
I don't think it will affect
I don't think it will affect the
presentation and if we could see the
whole if we get the description of the
whole of the slide before any more
questions on this slide and and
subsequent slides please
thank you
were there any more questions about this
one we'll move on to the next slide
I haven't done
no I haven't done
um before we move on to talk about new
actions added to this strategic aim I
want to highlight that there are five
actions from the original delivery plan
that have been transferred to the new
delivery plan the offices are continuing
to work on
in addition a new action has been added
to the delivery plan setting out our
ambition to build or require 65 new
homes in each district per year for each
of the next six years ensuring that all
new build homes have been in accordance
with the council's new design guide
specification and the new parking
strategy
this action is in alignment with details
set out in the recently published
housing revenue account business plan
the success of this action will result
in an increase of quality homes within
the districts which will contribute
positively to meeting housing needs
I I think councilor Hinton has got the
answer to the question
yes according to the annual monitoring
report
um page 18
baber had 47 self-builds last year
started and mid Suffolk had 106.
a question from Council heads just a
quick question
got it yeah
um on the the design of houses because
this report is extremely comprehensive
some might say it's too comprehensive
because some some of the subject matter
keeps on reoccurring as it goes through
probably because the Strategic games are
fairly close to each other uh design of
houses there's no mention anywhere of
homes for life which would mean that
instead of building houses specifically
for old people we will be building
houses that could be used by old people
but also it could be used by families uh
in the interim but I believe the
portfolio holder's got some an answer to
that
yes thank you Mr chairman um yeah if I
can just clarify that the
and go towards social housing and also
with the social housing we've got our
own housing guide that uh
um that was approved at full Council
only a few months ago and in that it's
got clear details about homes for life
to be designed in that way
in regards to the developers we'll try
and use that design guide as much as
possible but obviously our hands are
tied in making them do it but we will
use it where we possibly can with Market
builds as well I hope that answers your
question counselor Hinton
thank you
uh counteract me on
thanks Mr chairman I think it'd be fair
to say that
um as far as the design guide is going
then from the council's point of view
then the growth companies are
implementing those those design guides
and that certainly reflected in the
quality of the build that's been
finished off uh at the old Dunedin HQ
site where we built the first 32 homes
so I think that we're on the right track
thank you
um Casa Grande
thank you chairman
um I'm not sure if this is going to be
covered elsewhere
can I just inquire about the size of the
new homes built
um
it doesn't seem to be in in the past
enough
smaller homes for people to downsize to
to then free up the larger homes for for
the for larger families or for families
and I wondered if that is being has been
looked into and catered For please
so like one bedroom flats and that kind
of thing
there is a an action um which I'll talk
about later on in the presentation that
has been added with with Focus
back at a downsizing policy so that we
can look at a more efficient use of the
council stock
um
does that answer your question or is it
more about what size of houses we're
building
sorry both really because I think they
sort of work together really those two
aspects so because I know there's been a
problem or I understand there's been a
problem in the past where
um
people could have downsized because of
their their need but there was nothing
for them to downsize into so I wondered
if your policy going forward is now
catering for that type of situation
I believe that the the policy will cover
that when it's it's in its infancy at
the moment but it I think that will be
covered when they look at the the detail
of the policy
thank you thank you can we move on to
the yeah we've finished on that slide
Rebecca we'll move on to the next slide
and can we just have questions that are
specific to what's on that slide and
anything else we'll leave to the end
because it just might be covered as we
go through
thank you moving on to strategic aim too
there is a y
to meet the needs of a wide range of
different households
in terms of achievements we have
provided advice and encouragement to
community-led housing schemes on the
formation of Community Land trusts with
the objective of delivering new
affordable housing
route to affordable housing but provides
a valuable contribution
we have published a framework for making
investment decisions to increase the
overall supply of affordable housing
making use of the housing revenue
account and working
associations
um this affordable housing strategy is
an appendix to the reason we published
housing revenue account business plan
how
and before we move on to talk about the
new actions added to this strategic aim
I want to highlight that there are six
actions from the original delivery plan
that have been transferred to the new
delivery plan that offers
to work on
in terms of new actions a new action has
been added to this strategic aim to
focus on a new policy to encourage
tenants to downsize their homes this
would be approached sensitively and the
success of this action will result in a
more efficient use
well can we finish the slide first and
then we'll ask questions on that yeah
that's the end of that slide
sorry that is the end of that slide yeah
right okay fine thank you Council
Grandin
so sorry can you can I just sort of
re-ask that question now that we seem to
be on that slide
um so could you tell me what that new
policy means then please in relation to
what I was asking
what it will practice in a practical
sense please so the downsizing policy
will be looking at incentives I believe
to encourage people to um we're over
occupying their property to look at
moving to a smaller property so freeing
up a larger property for a household in
need
um and obviously that policy is
dependent on there being a supply of the
smaller properties being available
um
I think I'm going to have to get back to
you specifically about that if anybody
else wants to jump in
that does seem to have been the the
problem and it doesn't seem to be that
you're saying
and we will ensure that there is the
supply of
smaller properties for them to move into
so it's sort of you're making this
um idealized situation where you're
encouraging people to downsize but if
you haven't got anything provide to
provide them then that policy it falls
at the first hurdle doesn't it so that
seems to be a little bit of a problem to
me from from what you're saying but I
think this is a policy that's being
developed so we can't we can't comment
on a policy that's not not yet available
intention
dude ammo did you want to respond I
don't want to active Rebecca has been
saying we're in the middle of developing
an older person's housing strategy
looking at what what type of housing
what the needs are for the older
population so that will look at how many
what what sort of tenure do people want
to move into do they want sheltered do
they want their own self-contained
accommodation do they want Bungalows do
they want Flats so looking at truly
engaging with older residents within
baby Suffolk to find out what those
needs are and trying to engage the whole
population having that conversation
because we recognize that we've got an
aging population so
in order to answer that question we need
to have that engagement first to find
out what it is people want then to look
at how we're going to be delivering on
that and I think one of the first rounds
is always to talk to our existing
tenants to see if there is an appetite
for an on Docker patient scheme what
does that look like in some areas you
have Seaside and Country Homes in some
areas are given additional preference
you give them some sort of incentive to
help them to move so it's all a Movable
Feast at the moment so it's something
that we're currently exploring and we'll
come back of a more detailed
well let's see
Casa Grande New York follow-up question
yes I have thank you
um but it's not only older people that
may want to downsize to say a
one-bedroomed
um accommodation
um you know it it seems like we might
perhaps it needs to be looked at as to
what our supply
is to meet because it seems as I
understand it that some people may be
having to pay the extra
um
rent for a larger property when it's not
their fault that they haven't got
anything that
that downsized to when you know they'd
be quite content with
um a one-bedroom property but there
aren't enough for them to move into
um and it won't only be older people so
I'm glad that you've got that
um that you're looking into the needs of
older people and I would think some of
them would be or a lot of them would be
older people but there might be just
uh um or there's likely to be a range of
people who
um
family no longer with live with them and
could easily move downsize freeing up
their family size home but they're not
ready for
accommodation for older people they
wouldn't put themselves into
you know the older category so the um it
seems to be an opportunity missed if if
that's not being looked into uh can I
can I ask councilor John Osborne to
respond
thank you Mr chairman I think this is a
debate for when the policy comes forward
to Cabinet that's for sure and it looks
like it'd be an interesting debate
um and a challenging one as well but can
I just add that we cannot make people
move out of their existing accommodation
into a smaller unit a smaller home
rather
um we have to it's about encouraging
them to do so we can't make them do it
it's we're just not just wouldn't be
right morally right or legally right to
be able to do that I think also we need
to bear in mind that when we build or
acquire homes to add to our housing
stock
that's the point that we will look at
the need for that area and make sure
that we're providing either one bedroom
two bedroom three bedroom whatever the
need is
also it needs to be bear in mind that
when applications come forward to the
planning committee the uh for private
developers that they also look at that
need in that particular area to see if
that planning application is fulfilling
that need rather than just an
application coming forward
thank you councilor Osborne um Council
Matheson yeah thank you I I must say
chat I think it's going to be incredibly
difficult to separate out questions from
from sort of um
opinions as to what you know what ought
to be happening on this I mean my my
particular thought about under
occupation and downsizing is is actually
the incentives are are a half or less
than half
of the of the answer that's setting
aside what council Grand is saying about
you know are they there are the houses
there anyway sort of thing and that
really I think that providing support to
help people particularly senior citizens
downsizing it's such a challenging thing
to move house
um particularly downsizing move house
and actually incentives are are fine but
what they actually need is is a
labor-intensive
help
for them to actually move assuming
there's somewhere there anywhere and
that's very much an opinion not a
question but I just it's just very
difficult to yeah okay thank you thank
you for that that's a that's a point
that can be brought in mind when
officers are pretty
policy
can we can we move on to the next slide
please
we which is homelessness is prevented
and our services provide positive and
planned interventions
this strategic ranks directly to the
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy unlike the homes and
housing strategy the homelessness
reduction and rough sleeping strategy is
a statutory document and it's not been
refreshed this year
a statutory document it will be formally
reviewed in 2023 and a revised or new
strategy will be published in 2024
a new action has been added to the
delivery plan to this effect to the
current strategy and provide a new
document in 2024.
in terms of achievements some highlights
are we have developed and implemented a
comprehensive online advice service for
clients to Access housing options advice
we have developed a process for offering
short-term support and ongoing contacts
to monitor the progress of clients and
reduce the risk of repeated homelessness
from recovery accommodation
um we have created an informal
multi-agency panel to manage Monitor and
find Housing Solutions for the hardest
to house clients
um and we have rebranded the rent
deposit scheme and expanded the central
suffer collettings provision
before I move on to talk about new
actions added to this strategic aim I
want to highlight that there are seven
actions from the original delivery plan
that have been transferred to the new
delivery plan that officers are
continuing to work on
a further new action has been added to
the Strategic aim to ensure that housing
teams are working towards the aims and
supporting the objectives of the cost of
living crisis action plan this is of
Paramount importance to ensure that
homelessness is avoided wherever
possible
thank you are there any questions
councilor granted
thank you chairman
covert crisis
um there was a national policy to
um
home
um homeless people and we used hotels
and other
um
other other types of accommodation for
this and
as I understand it we didn't have any
homeless people at that time due to that
policy could you tell me what's the
current situation is with regard to that
and also bearing in mind the I can see
that you're you're going to have you're
planning to look at it during the coming
period but obviously we're about to hit
possibly hit a crisis now in the cost of
living
um and that might hopefully not but
might result in more homeless people
how how we
how are you going to deal with that in
the interim before 2024 please
am I yeah I'll take that question
um
we
in terms of dealing with the pending
crisis due to the cost of living we're
looking at doing some early prevention
work trying to engage with residents
before
they approach Us in terms of making
people aware of where they can go for
help and assistance working with local
cab this is advice bureaus so that
people know where to go and signpost
them for help obviously making good use
of the household support fund as well to
support residents
I'm a great believer of making sure
people know where to go for help and
understand what we can do for them so
we're making sure that all officers are
aware of the different options that
residents can go for and is obviously
trying to have early conversations with
residents you know making them aware
that if you have rentals don't just
leave it too late please do come and
speak to us we might be able to help and
assist you one of the things we have
noticed is that we may getting calls on
our demands for us to help people who
are homeowners so it's looking at how we
skill offices to understand where to
redirect people for help making sure
they understand that they can talk to
their providers making sure we have good
connections with local landlords and
agents so one of the things we want to
do is Outreach to local agents to say do
you have any tenants are experiencing
any difficulties have any issues with
Venture is that you may feel is
struggling please signpost them to us so
we basically want them to be able to
refer into our services so we can talk
to them as soon as possible we are part
of the cost of living working group at
the moment looking all the different
options out there for residents
I know from the last house or support
fund charge that we spent before the end
of September this year was that there's
a lot of fuel probability out there and
helping people manage their budgets a
lot better making sure people are
maximizing their incomes as well so
we're trying to do a bit of partnership
working with the Department of works and
pensions to maybe look at people to
maximize their income get better paying
jobs make sure they're getting all their
benefit entitlements so we're doing lots
of proactive things looking at our offer
in terms of triage and early prevention
you know what does that look like you
know and how can we reshape the service
so that is early intervention work truly
is happening
thank you
did you have a follow-up and then I'll
come to council acting Young
yeah
thank you for that chairman
um yes thank you very much
um for that answer which
I I like that proactive approach
um so that was one half of my question
answered thank you the other half was um
with regard to the current homeless
um do you know the number of current
homeless people we have in our districts
please and what has been done to
current homework homeless please
I'll get the numbers up but in terms of
current homelessness what we're trying
to do is engage with landlords engage
with hosts to hold on to people for
longer sort of negotiating with them to
look at how they can hold on to people
why we find them alternative options we
do refer people to Central Suffolk
lettings to try and help them find
something private rented we encourage
people to definitely
try and find their own accommodation and
we want assist to preventing deposit so
we do try and get them to be as
proactive as they can be obviously with
the help of their personal housing plans
uh
that's what we're trying to do in terms
of preventing them in terms of numbers
trying to find the numbers rather than
we rush you on the page now but thank
you
um as at the end of September we'll be
taking 46 applications in Baylor and we
had accepted
19 in prevention Duty and
nine in relief which means if we've
accepted convention Duty they can remain
in their current accommodation whilst to
try and relieve or prevent them from
being homeless and try and keep them in
their existing home and the nine and
relief means that we haven't been able
to prevent the homelessness and we place
them in temporary accommodation and
that's just for babe and if I go across
I can tell you what's happening over at
Mid Suffolk
in September Mick Suffolk we had 47
applications were taken from people
making homeless application 20 we
accepted a prevention Duty and
seven we accepted a relief Duty so seven
went into temporary accommodation
in terms of those numbers you want to do
more prevention which means they're not
being placed into temporary
accommodation which means officers are
working really hard to either keep them
in their existing home which is which is
our first duty if that's not successful
we will then try and find an alternative
accommodation we have 56 days to do that
so if we try and do that within that
timeline you know so as much as we can
we try and use all the tools available
to us
I guess like say thank you very much for
that really comprehensive answer thank
you
and and would it be possible for those
numbers to be put in our um
um minutes please
thank you yeah thank you
um councilor Osborne is it a response to
that question yeah thank you
I will be brief um yeah those those
figures that you asked for are always
reported in the quarterly monitoring
report and also to add to amar's
comments we are I'm not can't answer for
Mid Suffolk on this one but in baber we
are looking to add into our temporary
accommodation so that we can House
people when they come forward as
homeless however as Mara said the focus
is on prevention rather than cure very
much so thank you
thank you councilman Young
German
um I think and last answered the
question I was going to ask although it
does leave a another question which is I
think you said certainly mid-suffer
you'd had 47 applications and as far as
I can do from the mass you've taken care
of 27 of them so what's happened about
the other 20.
generally what will what that generally
means is that person might not actually
be homeless you know so in terms of
officers have to be satisfied that
someone is homeless threatened with
homelessness is eligible so in those
circumstances you may get someone who
calls through to our service we start
taking the application but as we go
through they don't meet the statutory
requirements for an application to be
taken but we'll still give them advice
very much for that answer I think it
would be
a Bissell to qualify that response in
that regard going forward thank you
thank you casa castan
chairman
um where we're talking about um refuges
and um
do we aim to um put so there's a bit on
them I haven't actually got the um page
up now but there's a star bit that says
um am figure includes
um Refuge which I assume is for domestic
abuse do we have provision for that
within mid-suffolk or do we prefer to
use
um
refugees outside of mid-suffolk and
and for other districts
who use a refuge Within mid-suffolk
um I need to clarify that um but do you
get what I'm yeah asking yeah because
usually you're right usually where you
have people clean domestic violence so
you should not say for them to stay
within their districts I think
uh what we tend to do is we have
self-contained units that we can move
around between both districts so if
someone couldn't be in Suffolk we might
tend to place them in the baby area and
vice versa I think that's some of the
luxury that we have but if we needed to
try and acquire accommodation elsewhere
that's something that we would look to
do but we are continually looking at our
temporary combination stock to make sure
it's meeting the needs the residents
especially when it comes to domestic
abuse so that's always taken into
consideration you know depending on
where the person's approaching for how
safe they are general rule of thumb is
because someone's feeling domestic
abusive they're generally not safe in
either districts the law does allow them
to approach any local Authority in the
country where they feel they are safe to
make an application so also through the
Gateway we're able to move residents
around the partner bodies and our
registered providers as well so we have
a lot of good tools and options
available for those who are fleeing
domestic abuse
other
depart from mid-suffer convey
come back with
putting up their
um
customers or whatever you want to um
call it that need a refuge outside of
their District
I think we'd always work in partnership
with the other District councils as we
should do the same way that if we had an
issue we'd go to them for help and
assistance so we have a really good
working relationship with them so that's
something that we would definitely
explore
thank you very much
anyone else or do we now move on to the
next slide
yeah thank you Rebecca
okay moving on to strategic strategic
aim for which is baber and mid Suffolk
is an effective social landlord known
for delivering quality services
there have been a lot of changes to the
delivery plan for this strategic aim due
to the publication of the social housing
white paper and the specific
requirements it places on babamid
Suffolk as a social landlord
in terms of achievements we have
included measures to improve the
environmental performance of our housing
stock within the housing revenue account
business plan and capital program
we have put in place measures to ensure
we learn from every complaint
we have put in place a new approach to
managing complaints of anti-social
Behavior
we have reviewed our approach to
managing void or redundant stock and
have identified measures to make better
use of such properties
we have reviewed our housing stock
profile and commenced a program to
dispose of properties that are expensive
and or low demand
there have been a lot of changes to the
delivery plan for this strategic aim due
to the publication of the social housing
white paper and as such there are only
two actions from the original delivery
plan that have been transferred to the
new delivery plan in addition there are
nine new actions added to the delivery
plan and these focus on
co-creating developing and launching
attendant engagement strategy and this
is to enable tenants to hold baby
mid-suffolk to account on performance in
areas that are important to them in a
way that suits them
um we'll be refreshing the council's
income strategy to ensure that we are
best placed to meet the needs of our
tenants who are experiencing financial
difficulties and to ensure that income
to the housing revenue account to
provide new and improved services for
tenants is protected
we'll be working with our tenants to
constantly improve the ways we
communicate with them about matters
affecting their homes and neighborhoods
as we want to ensure that our tenants
feel that they are treated with respect
and dignity
and Building Services is to undergo a
full diagnostic assessment leading to
transformation of the service to ensure
that Building Services is in an
optimized position to meet the
requirements of the building safety act
and to contribute to meeting climate
emergency objectives
success in these new actions will result
in compliance with the social housing
Regulators requirements and contribute
towards delivering a modern landlord
service that meets the current and
future needs of our tenants
thank you Rebecca are there any
questions on this slide please
Council Grandin and then councilor
Mathison
thank you chairman
um can I just
check
um in your section on achieved put in
place a new approach to manage
complaints of anti-social Behavior
[Music]
um
one of the problems I've had in in a
couple of situations in my world which
is hardly South
um have been where tenants have been put
in situations where
they have completely different lifestyle
to the other tenants that they live
close to
um
or
in in another situation
they have a different
need due to a particular social
need that a particular particular tenant
might have
um
so you say that you've achieved a new
approach to anti-social Behavior would
that include
um ensuring that the right tenants are
put in
um into housing that is
um compatible with people that they live
near our other the other tenants that
they live near does that include that
kind of thing so you know one person's
anti-social behavior isn't antisocial in
to another age group for example has
that is that included in that statement
please
Council Osborne thank you Mr chairman I
think actually councilor Grandin is
referring to aim seven and we've already
said it's in relation to the allocations
policy that you're referring to and we
have added
um a new action plan in the action plan
that's to carry out a health check on
our current lettings and allocation
policy to ensure that the current
Arrangements continue to meet the needs
of the councils and our residents so I
think councilor grandin's concern is
actually covered in that in that new
action within the plan
thank you very much are you happy with
that councilor Brandon yes thank you
thank you very much are there uh
councilman Mathison you are next thank
you yeah the I just wanted to suggest
that maybe
um the
scrutiny committee should put the tenant
engagement
um
on on its work plan as something it
seems to me that the going back years
and years and years that we've always
had considerable difficulty with housing
boards and tenant committees and one
thing another and you know so many
things have tried and not really worked
and I mean it's right to see it it's
sitting there that we we're going to
look at it again good
um but it really is something that
probably needs a wide
um
so wide range of different people's
inputs and so forth and that maybe the
scrutiny committee is a vehicle for
doing that
yeah thank you for that suggestion we'll
consider that when when we come to the
work plan and when
um chairs and vice chairs meet next week
thank you uh happy to move on now to the
next slide
please Rebecca
okay so strategic game five homes are in
high quality sustainable environments
served by jobs and Community facilities
appropriate Green Space effective
transport links and other necessary
infrastructure
so in terms of achievements we have
ensured our homes and housing strategy
is aligned to our economic and Community
strategies and complements our
commitment to stimulate housing-led
growth and economic prosperity
we have reviewed the community
infrastructure expenditure framework I
don't know if we have infrastructure
continues through regular proactive
discussions with infrastructure
providers and the community
and we have delivered two separate
infrastructure funding statements for
both councils
um before we move on to talk about new
actions added to this strategic aim I
want to highlight that there are five
actions from the original delivery plan
that have been transferred to the new
delivery plan that officers are
continuing to work on
in terms of new actions added to the
delivery plan for this strategic game
we'll be focusing on preparing for
biodiversity offsetting when
biodiversity net gain becomes compulsory
in 2023
by identifying sites and pursuing
opportunities for securing net gains in
areas that maximize the benefits
provided the successful completion of
this action will require partnership
working and will result in an increase
in biodiversity within the districts
thank you do I have any questions please
Council Matheson yeah yeah obviously I'm
very proud that the first site that
we've actually bought for biodiversity
purposes in my world but really what I
wanted to ask was in terms of that that
new um
that that new panel there
um what
um kind of office a member grouping or
whatever is is actually
going to be working on that I think to
to know because it's it's so new it's so
new to the councils
um that we should be doing this that um
you know
are we putting the responsibility on
members to look out for things or
officers to monitor land that's up for
sale or whatever
um you know we can do random things but
um what you're setting out there is is a
you know it's a definite intention to do
it and I just wonder what the mechanism
is going to be thank you
I'd have to get back to you on the
actual detail of how it's going to work
the
um the officer who's responsible for
that um action is Richard palmy the
biodiversity project manager
um and I don't know the specifics of how
it's going to work
um going forward because it's in its
infancy but I can get back to you
with some information
thank you chairman
um I don't know if you're going to cover
this later
um but on your strategic it came five on
our papers
um you refer to being on track with
investigating the viability of
installing electric vehicle points on
our housing estate
um can I just ask you some questions
with regard to that please
[Music]
um
I are the plans
to install
individual charging points or are they
charging points sort of by you know on
the pavement or something for kind of
shared
um or in you know in the vicinity
because
it just seems to me if they're on
individual houses it seems a costs a
high cost to
[Music]
um
to our district for
services that might not be used whereas
if I don't know if your plan is to have
them you know as shared facilities in
near the estate you know how how do you
plan to do that please
thank you
thank you councilor I think that's all
part of the viability assessment that
all needs to be undertaken by the
climate change manager so I think that's
a pretty valid point I think it's one of
these
thank you Rebecca I think we can move on
to aim six
okay
moving on
I'm sorry I've gone too far
same six right aim six best use is made
of private sector land and private
accommodation across the district
in terms of achievements already made
towards the strategic game we have
worked with Civic authorities to develop
and Implement a new approach to
delivering disabled facilities grants
we have developed and implemented a
project to increase awareness of the
availability of support for private
tenants in respective housing conditions
and Energy Efficiency standards this was
supported by a social media campaign in
addition to radio and TV adverts
we have increased the number of empty
homes which the council supports back
into use this has been supported by a
dedicated empty homes officer working
across both districts and a new empty
homes policy to drive work in this area
forward
um
before we go on to new actions I want to
highlight that there were three actions
from the original delivery plan that
would have been transferred
sorry free actions from the original
delivery plan that have been transferred
to the new delivery plan that officers
are continuing to work on
in terms of new actions a new action has
been added to this strategame focusing
on promoting and supporting Energy
Efficiency in homes by targeting all f
and g energy performance weighted
properties in the private rented sector
the successful completion of this action
will result in a decrease in f and g
rated properties in the private rented
sector in the districts which will
contribute to the aims of the cost of
living crisis action plan by reducing
energy costs for residents
a further newly added action is to fully
assess the potential demand to support
the various emerging Refugee and Asylum
Seeker accommodation needs
the successful completion of this action
will provide much needed Clarity on the
way forward to meetingcreased housing
needs whilst working in partnership with
Suffolk County Council
thank you Rebecca are there any
questions on AMC's Council scarf
first please
thank you chair hope you can hear
because that's the microphone over there
on on the actual papers for strategic
game six there are a number of
interlinked things which build on
perhaps um
success of central Suffolk nettings by
telling us about the establishment of a
new landlord's forum
to advise and assist landlords I think
that is absolutely crucial in this day
and age because land is quite often our
have one property and
it can lead to all sorts of problems and
they don't know what grants are
available and I think in assisting them
to upgrade their f and g properties and
even deep energy rated properties 2C
which is what we should be aspiring to I
think we doing absolutely everything
that we can so I think
the question would be how quickly do you
think you could establish an effective
landlord's form because I think that
could play a really crucial role in
ensuring access to private sector rented
stock which will assist our residents
thank you
is that something you can answer Rebecca
or do you need to talk to a colleague
and perhaps provide another announcement
outside the meeting
thank you is that okay
um councilman Muller I had next and then
councilor Grant
all right okay
um you mentioned on this particular
slide about
um the refugees and Asylum Seekers Etc
um what is the latest position with
those refugees Asylum Seekers from
Ukraine who's six months with their host
families will be coming to an end this
month have you been able to house any of
those families or are you finding
difficulty housing them I'm particularly
interested in that that particular issue
thank you
foreign
we've managed to house one family today
in the private range sector so far but
we are actually experiencing extreme
difficulty due to the lack of Supply
within the private rental market
obviously there's an affordability issue
as well
so we recognize that as an issue we're
working very closely with the other
districts looking at our offer to
landlords in the private rental sector
we're trying to make sure that we are
fair and Equitable across the board so
that we're not making one cohort of
applicants more attractive than others
but we are mindful that the six months
is coming up so we're trying to work
with hosts
to see if they can hold on to the
tenants that I guess a little bit longer
whilst we try and help them to find
alternative accommodation but it is
proving to be quite a difficult
experience
that counts the ground
my questions be answered thank you
thank you no further questions can we
move on to the next aim then please
Rebecca
okay so strategic aim seven which is
people living vibrant and well-connected
communities and homes and communities
continue to meet the changing needs of
residents
in terms of achievements towards his
strategic aim we have developed a
community strategy which encourages
greater participation and involvement
we've ensured the draft joint local plan
includes policies to increase the supply
of Specialists and accessible housing
and before we move on to talk about new
actions added to the Strategic aim in
order to highlight that there are four
actions from the original delivery plan
that have been transferred
to the new delivery plan that officers
are continuing to work on
looking ahead we'll be focusing on the
commissioning of an older people's homes
development strategy this would
contribute to ensuring greater
partnership working and ensuring Choice
within the arena of older people's
housing we'll also be carrying out a
health check on our current lettings and
allocation policy to ensure that the
current Arrangements continue to meet
the needs of the councils and our
residents
thank you are there any questions on
this slide please
no well oh sorry counselor Hinton
um just a quick one on the older
person's strategies we within various
parts of this document and it does it's
a very comprehensive document
tends to sort of cover the same ground
several times over during the course of
the document it does highlight the fact
that both baber and mid-suffolk have
higher than national average populations
of older people in the countryside in
the rural areas rather than in the urban
areas which obviously presents a
challenge
what is being done to develop a strategy
that is going to give us or enable these
well these
residents to stay in well-connected
communities bearing in mind that most of
the new builds that are happening across
baber in particular I'm not quite sure
what the figures are for mid-suffolk 60
of the new bills in Baba are in the
rural areas so we're effectively
increasing the potential for
isolation within the rural communities
by the older people if we don't come up
with some sort of strategy to address
the problem
am I able to answer that question yeah
um one of the things that we're seeking
to do is part of that this strategy is
actually to engage with residents first
to find out
where do you want the the US to develop
older people's homes what type of homes
do you want developed as well and it's
also looking at how do we keep people in
their homes I think it's always done
about porting people out where they are
so you're absolutely correct so most
people want to stay where they are so
how do we have a strategy that helps
them to do that and that is involving
partnership working across the board
with other key stakeholders like Health
social care so we need to be talking to
everybody who has a stakeholder in
delivering Services as well as I think
we need to hear from residents actually
because they're the key partner because
from my perspective somebody who's older
now is very different to when a lot of
shelter schemes were designed people are
really Keen to keeping dependent and
living in their own home so how do we do
that and deliver that and what does that
look like so I want us to be we're
looking to do a survey we talk to all
residents not just our tenants talk to
all residents and ask them what that
looks like for them and what they would
like to be delivered so I think that's
the first protocol in developing the
strategy is having the conversation of
residents first
thank you for that uh Council scarf and
then councilor Adrian Osborne
okay
um well it's actually on the delivery
plan but it is sort of vaguely referred
to up there so I'll ask the question
anyway
um 7D on the delivery plans to bring
forward Innovative Redevelopment
opportunities for redundant and
underused sheltered accommodation and it
mentions there in the what does the
success look like as successful pilot
Approach at hoxton and I wonder if
perhaps we can have some just a brief
detail what does that look like in terms
of Redevelopment because this is one
area which I think we've had a problem
with over the years where we've had
perhaps more rural locations we've
shared with accommodation which have
lots of vacancies so how does that look
so up here Robert thank you
yeah I think it cancels a few question
um yeah I mean we um we named hoxson as
the development there because
to let me have struggled for a number of
years
partially produced location I think
local transport is a challenge as well
there's What the residents have fed back
to me so we'll we recognize that there
needs to be a bit of a review of our
sheltered housing and how appropriate is
it for 20 too and how appropriate is it
going forward thinking about the things
Emma has contributed there around the
older person's strategy so it's all part
of the same question really is how can
we make sure that those properties
remain attractive as a general service
model of sheltered housing but also on
an individual scheme basis are they
viable are they going to continue to
serve the needs of the communities and
the local housing needs there so hoxton
is there we have been engaging with the
residents so I don't want to set hairs
running around what the outcome of that
review will be we are acknowledging that
there are challenges in certain areas
and Hawks in this one where we're having
significant challenges and have had for
a period of time so we recognize we need
to do something Innovative and different
thank you uh councilor Adrian Osborne
and then Council Matheson
thank you Mr chairman uh this is more of
a question for our portfolio how about
um
some time now members have been raising
issues uh and turns around Gateway Being
Fit for purpose
apologies if I've missed this but are we
covering this in our action plan
counselor
thank you Mr chairman rather strange
getting one from councilor Osborne but
there you go
um yeah I think I've actually already
alluded to this and uh I did ask
officers to add and it's it is on there
and 7.1 of strategic seven which is to
carry out the health check on our
current letters and allocation policy to
ensure that the current Arrangements
continue to meet the needs of the
councils and our residents and that
includes the Gateway as well and I
understand looking at this that that
health check has been completed and I've
just sent an email to our officer asking
for what those recommendations are so
it'd be interesting to see what those
recommendations are but that health
check would include with the allocation
policy also the look at the look at
Gateway to see that it is being
effective and it is fit for purpose
thank you Mr Jim
thank you are you happy with the
response
Council I was born
oh yeah very bad thank you very much Mr
chairman I could be probably not getting
any lunch today
councilman Matheson
thank you yeah I'm just wondering
whether this
um
any consideration that with with the
hoxton example and there will be others
in in our kind of larger Villages where
we've got the these and you know
I've heard that kind of problems been
been running with us for quite a while
um that um the possibility of actually
supporting
Services particularly I suppose I'm
thinking about
um
you know the you know community
community run shops open for three days
a week or whatever
um you know to doing more to support and
encourage things like that or you know
retention or
all starting
um you know as a as a different way of
approaching the problem
um is that a matter for housing or is
that something you'd rather discuss with
communities because it does seem to be
it's building up the community that's
yeah
yeah
uh Robert I could try if I'm not
coughing sorry it's the end of a call
don't worry anymore
um yeah just do it just to say I think
it's a it's a good point I think we need
to look at all the options there it's a
question for the local economy and
communities as well and I think that
links in nicely to the outcomes
framework and the objectives there which
is a broader thing looking at you know
what does a Vibrant Community look like
and what the services look like for our
residents so I think it's a good a good
point and just to reassure you that
corporate managers are working across
teams to to look at those kind of things
but no it's a it's a good point well
made thank you
thank you uh Council actor Young
chairman um I observe
from a lot of the commentary that there
are some conflicting requirements within
the homeless and housing strategy and
the community strategies and I note that
councilor Hinton
claims that a lot of the development new
housing development in baber at least is
occurring in rural districts so that
would suggest that we're building bigger
communities but I guess my concern is
that if we're building more houses in
rural areas to what extent are we
taking account of the fact that a people
need to downsize and and then that
conflicts with them not wanting to move
from their homes and and and the need to
essentially provide
[Music]
um
the the the the the
structure of whereby
um those developments actually catered
to the strategies that we're developing
for housing in communities and I and
also I'm I'm I'm very conscious of the
fact that throughout the discussion so
far there's not really been any nod to
well-being
um which I think is also an important
aspect particularly with regard to
um more Auto folk like myself
thank you is that something you can
address or is that sort of a cross
service
issue
I think it's not just older folk I think
it's any any folk living on their own
potentially would need support or access
to services
I
um I I I I think that there are probably
points there that we would we would like
to refer to a cabinet when this goes
forward and for cabinet then to decide
where best they can be addressed if
you're happy with that
thank you uh councilor Jan Osborne and
then I'll come to council Matheson
that we
[Music]
we do include links to those various
other strategies in community including
the community strategy the well-being
strategy as well so and the cost of
living crisis action plan five-point
plan so we are very conscious of those
other strategies within our own action
plan and as our officer has already
alluded to we do work very closely
across all the services sometimes you'll
get a bit of conflict but we work very
hard to reduce that conflict to an
absolute minimum but we do work across
the services we're not just isolated in
our own little box and work within the
housing box but no there's clear links
in the action plan to those strategies
including the well-being strategy
because it is very very key to what
we're trying to deliver on in housing
thank you councilor Osborne Council
Matheson yeah I I thank um thank the
portfolio holder for that point that
does cover someone I wanted to say that
the the aim five
um I think hidden within aim five in the
detail will be those connections and the
fact that improving the environment etc
etc you know we do recognize that that
is
you know that is part of well-being
as well as part of um housing so to
speak thank you
thank you Council Matheson can we now
move on to the next aim please Rebecca
okay moving on to strategic aim eight
which is everyone has a suitable home
and residents are able to give us
healthily safely independently as
possible within sustainable communities
in terms of achievements we have
identified strategic objectives for
carbon reduction from our housing stock
to contribute to corporate and
county-wide climate emergency objectives
these were set out in the recently
approved housing revenue account
business plan
we have prepared a board specification
for new build Council stock to include
consideration of passive Technologies
and measures to increase accessibility
again this was set out in the recently
approved new build design guide which
was an appendix the housing revenue
account business plan
um there are six actions from the
original delivery plan that have been
transferred to the new delivery plan
that offices are continuing to work on
but in terms of new actions a new action
has been added to this strategic aim to
take forward measures to improve the
environmental performance of our housing
stock this will contribute to reducing
carbon emissions and meeting National
targets for all social homes to be EPC
rating FC or above by 2030. this will
also contribute to corporate and
county-wide climate emergency objectives
and links to the cost of living crisis
action plan as it will reduce energy
costs for tenants
thank you very much are there any
questions on this aim
if not we'll move straight on to the
next one please Rebecca
finally aim strategic aim nine both
councils have strong relationships with
residents developers and other partners
that enable us to deliver housing
infrastructure and services effectively
and to innovate where appropriate
in terms of progress towards achieving
this strategic aim we continue to
maintain our strong relationship with
Holmes England in order to optimize the
funding streams for which we are
eligible
we continue to work collectively as
local authorities have been Suffolk to
support the effective delivery of
services in relation to housing through
the means of the Suffolk housing board
we continue to provide support to
Neighborhood planning groups to create
and make effective plans
and we continue to engage regularly with
registered providers and potential new
providers to increase the supply of new
homes
before we move on to new actions I want
to highlight that there are three
actions from the original delivery
delivery plan that have been transferred
to the new delivery plan that offer are
continuing to work on
next we will be focusing on developing a
neighborhood strategy and policy setting
out how we will work with our tenants to
improve the areas they live this will
include reviewing our approach to the
management of garages
the successful completion of this action
will result in a new strategy and policy
adopted and targets set for improvement
in satisfaction and a set of service
standards with a linked set of key
performance indicators
a further new action sets out how the
Suffolk housing board will be
identifying and taking forward projects
which address housing inequalities that
have been exacerbated by the covid-19
pandemic which meet the criteria for
funding allocated by Suffolk public
sector readers and this will bring
benefits for residents in both districts
thank you very much
do we have any questions
on a
on a nine or any general questions
um I'm interested in
watch
what direction you
've garages
um
councilor Osborne knows that I have a
situation in in my ward where
um a resident is seeking to rent one of
our garages and
um you know
nothing he's not heard from anyone
um and he's Keen to do so but this might
make you think that there aren't many
people looking for garages and perhaps
there aren't but I just wondered your
your direction at the moment please
is there a few Robert thank you
thanks and I think the innovision choir
I think I'm familiar with the one but
I'm happy to have a conversation outside
of the uh the meeting about that
know garages we have an awful lot of
garages among across both districts and
they often fall to the bottom of the
pecking order in terms of priorities so
this is this project here is about
putting in a bit of a review as to how
we might be best manage those going
forward making sure that we can let them
quickly our waiting lists are clear and
there's a bit more transparency around
the process for people to understand you
know if they're applying for a garage uh
what the process is um fast and
straightforward I won't go into details
now but um but people don't necessarily
want a garage that various
foreign
[Laughter]
we
need to
details our garage service and we'd like
to make it
make it thank you thank you
councilor Hinton and then cancel April
thank you
um you mentioned that you're working
closely with the housing housing board
to secure funding etc for social housing
housing Etc
uh bearing in mind that our current
policies but I think in both councils
say that we want about 30 percent
affordable housing out of any
development
and we've got in both councils a
considerable number of applications that
haven't been started
are there any proposals to
work closer with developers to try and
get some of these
development started because when we got
sort of 10 years worth of
permissions or housing Target already
granted in terms of commissions it does
rather sort of make a bit of a joke of
giving more and more permissions when
nothing's actually started on some of
these sites and just for for Council
epinions to benefit uh in last year in
mid-suffolk 148 homes were built in
urban areas
524 were built in rural areas so that's
higher than 60 in the rural areas so
we're both in similar situations in
terms of most of the development is
taking place in rural areas rather than
in urban areas
yeah thank you for that um
was there a question that yes
addressing the planning yeah is it is it
one sorry I mean is it is it one that
you can answer or is it is it more a
joint local plan no we we need to yeah
thank you very much
uh
Council Equity um
thank you Mr chairman thank you
councilor thank you for those statistics
uh I really appreciate it
um and actually I have a subsidiary to
councilor hinton's question which is if
we have that many and I'm sure you can't
answer it but someone needs to be
looking into it if we have that many
outstanding applications for development
that haven't been exercised should we be
not thinking to withdraw them uh or do
something about enforcing them that
that's kind of um
the first the first point
um
and with regard to garages
we have rather a lot of them as the
officer has mentioned and I guess there
are two questions one is do we need that
many and B if we don't what's the plan
for getting rid of them and putting
something useful in their place
is that a plan that you're going to come
forward with after doing some research
or is it something you can answer now
thank you for your question I think um
my focus has been on my responsibility
as corporate manager for tenant services
around managing the current garages in
their current form there was a review
well there has been some reviews carried
out as to suitability for garage sites
and what we might do with the land let's
sit on if they're in low demand so there
is a piece of work going on but not
something I can comment on directly
um
I think it's a good point
Castle Journal spawn
thank you Mr chairman if I could just
add to that there's a comprehensive
report coming to Cabinet in January on
the garage review because there was a we
were hoping that a lot of the garage
sites would be suitable for development
but it's not proven to be the case it's
proven to be more challenging than we
anticipated so we've sort of set up a
traffic light system on the various
sites throughout baber and mid Suffolk
but there'll be a report coming forward
to Cabinet in January
thank you
right I think we've finished questions
so can we move on to debate
councilor
councilman Muller
thank you very much chair
um a very very good report thank you
very much for that really enjoyed
reading that
um the reason I raised about the
refugees I had the opportunity back in
August this year I was invited to an
open evening which was hosted by The
Stone Market Tesco manager where the
Tesco's happened to be Mike Ward where
he had the evening for Ukrainian
refugees and their host and I did speak
to a number of the refugees that were
there and some of them were family some
of them were single people and the
majority of their hosts what they're
living with who were in the rural areas
and one of the biggest concerns they had
was there was no public transport to get
them so they were very keen to move into
the towns and I'm wondering you know
I've heard in the past where we had were
the Afghan refugees where most of them
prefer to live in the towns rather than
in the rural areas purely because a
there was more of their community that
they could um liaise with and we've got
a similar position I read in the paper
uh over the weekend where there's the
Novotel Hotel in IPS which is being
taken over 85
refugees or migrants that have crossed
the channel and the leader labor the
labor or the leader of the Ipswich
Borough Council was complaining that
there's only about three that in other
sort of hotels across the district so
you obviously liaise with your
colleagues in Ipswich because obviously
they probably couldn't
um Haze all of those so I'm actually
interested going forward and thank you
for your answer regarding there is a
shortage of private housing
social housing where are these people
going to be housed because it's not
really satisfactory for families to be
housed in hotels for any length of time
perhaps just a thing I bring up into
debate chair thank you
I will try my best thank you it's not
easy I appreciate it I think I think
it's a situation we hadn't envisaged
back in March 2022 that we'd be in this
situation
um I think the six months
the idea of the six-month hosting was
hopefully that the homes for Ukraine
um applicants will be able to resolve
their issues you know get into some sort
of work be able to apply for benefits
which is why they were passported
through so they didn't have to do the
habitual residency check so I think
we're in an unprecedented times it's not
just maybe mid-southics I think it's the
whole country and what we're going to do
with people we don't know that's the
honest answer we will try our best to
house them where we can
um definitely putting families into BNB
is not ideal
um
the legislation and guidance has been
changed when it comes to homes in
Ukraine we technically lawfully can
house them in BNB for longer than six
weeks however it is recognized that it's
not uh hotels aren't ideal for families
it's not conducive it doesn't help young
children to thrive it impacts on their
mental well-being so we have a statutory
due to them if they end up being
homeless and we will use our statute
duties to accommodate and help them so
if that means that we move them on to
more settled accommodation in terms of
self-contained type of accommodating
that's what we would have to do so we
are looking at our options of the
numbers we might be looking at what does
that look like and what do we have
available to us so that is something
that we are constantly looking at
because regardless of anything that
happens if they end up being homeless
and meet that statute definition our
duties kick in and we will have to
accommodate them and it will mean that
we will move them as swiftly as we can
through the BNB route being B's are only
using emergency situations so if we
don't have anything else available to
Boston we will look at what else we have
I appreciate it
thank you thank you
um has anyone given any thought as
looked at the recommendations and giving
you any thought to any proposal uh
Council Matheson yeah yeah I must admit
I haven't looked at that aspect of it
there were a few points that I noted
that I were clearly not questions but
um views that I wanted to put
um so this seems to be the time to come
back over those
um on the
I'm number one
was it yeah on AIM number one the
um we're working to the you know the new
design guide I I like to suggest that
really the new design guide is not
not ambitious enough and not up to date
effectively because we've just had a
discussion with with officers about a
potential Redevelopment
um site
that's to say our own site
um and it's the world we're hoping to
achieve epcb I said well that's that's
just not good enough we shouldn't be
building
houses to that standard and he said well
you know the answer is well it's going
to meet the design guide and that's just
not good enough anymore so that seems to
me a fundamental problem that we're
never going to achieve a really good
good average if we we carry on building
stuff that isn't to the to the highest
standard so that that's really one point
I wanted to make and closely related to
that on page what's up page 11 I just
want to see which aim that was a minute
um
the page 11 I see I'm here aim six where
we're talking again about the energy
performance certificates and so on
um
I was trying to untangle in my mind
about this decreasing the f and g
um
you know there's so how do we know
how do we know what the properties that
are that bad
um unless they actually come
back onto the market and if they come
back onto the market the government has
got a yardstick which I I forget what it
is but
um that they can't be rented out unless
they're at least is it f or or is it e
or is it shifting soon up one up a notch
um so how do we know and
um
and aren't they all going to be weeded
out anyway
um and I would have thought that success
is going to look like eliminating f and
g frankly not not decreasing it
so I I think that with any unless
there's any bit more help about
how that actually works that you can
give us
um
as to the you know what government is
saying about that and then the final
Point related into all of that is that
the the counties just bought some
um infrared scanners
and um the purpose of these is to look
at properties and see how leaky they are
in heat which is obviously going to be
work for the winter
um starting soon and and whether that's
got some part to play you know whether
we should they're only getting 10 for
the whole County at the moment and
they're they're going to be lent out to
voluntary groups I wonder whether we
ought to be buying half a dozen of our
own because I do remember years ago we
actually got
such a device and looked at the um the
needed Market HQ site which is currently
being demolished
to see how very leaky it all was
um and it was interesting that the the
leakiest bit was actually the window
frames
fascinatingly
um so can we can we think about actually
getting
the equipment to go and look for these
these properties but also you know how
is it going to work generally in in
decreasing and I would say it ought to
be for success or to look ought to be to
eliminate G and then to eliminate F over
a
not very many years and thank you thank
you councilman I wonder whether these
are points that we want to move we want
to pass on to Cabinet when they're
considering the strategy rather than for
every point every point that we make to
have an answer to today
um you say you're happy with that so
there are points that officers will have
noted
uh councilor Osborne thank you Mr
chairman actually on that point this is
not going to cabinets it's just for
scrutiny to scrutinize the only thing I
would suggest is that any
recommendations that come out of this
obviously officers will look at to see
how we're going to implement them but it
isn't going back to cabin it's not going
back can I on that on that first point
on the design guide the design guide
that's referred to in strategic aim one
is a design guide to guide the Council
on houses we acquire or build ourselves
to add to our social housing stock it
isn't relevant although we're going to
try and encourage developers to refer to
that design guide we haven't got it
hasn't got any clout in as far as
developers go you really need to be
looking at the Suffolk design guide
which is the guide that will give when
it comes when an application comes to
the planning committee
there is sorry Mr chairman yeah that
there is the design guy that's referred
to in strategic aim1 is the one that
we're using in relation to houses that
we build or acquire to add to our house
in stock
right thank you so thank you for the
correction so that our comments then
don't go to Cabinet
um
although that was the suggestion I think
from offices that that we do pass our
comments to Cabinet
um
Council actor Young
uh well before I make a comment message
I wonder if any of the officers could uh
tell us what is the average EPC rating
of the housing stock in our district is
and how that compares nationally
does anyone have that available or is
that would that be a written answer
can't say definitely because I because I
got that in my head sitting here but I
do know that I believe that about 28 is
already on an EPC C
and as for the other figures we're
endeavoring to reach those by 2030 to
get them to a scene but I haven't got
the figures who are on f and g I'm
afraid
so it's probably not as relevant what
the average is but how many are in each
of the different bands is what we
probably need to know and then that's
something that we can use as Benchmark
to see where we are in 12 months time
Council Matheson yeah I think Council
Osborne was those those figures was
referring to our stock our stock and I
think that the question was actually a
wider question than that now it happens
at three or four years ago I took a
great deal of interest in these matters
and and pursued them through
um through our building control people
and planning people and up to the
ministry
um
to to try and get some kind of a
yardstick that we
we changed object
of working or could work and so on and
um it is
it is quite difficult to get hold of
satisfactory figures for for the
districts at large as council's question
um but we we need to try and get what as
much as we can of that information
um you know because then we know how
difficult the problem is and so on and
so on
um yeah our own stock easy you know we
know what they all are
um the rest of it as I was you know
eluding in my my point earlier that the
we find out
on an individual
um
well both I think both owner occupied
and private rented accommodation as they
go through the marketplace we find out
what the uh what the EPC is
um now whether we can actually Garner
that information going through the
market I don't know but that's
seems as if that's the best that we can
get
of of what the position is across the
whole market across the whole District
sorry
yeah thank you
I'm not sure councilman's dissertation
was very helpful actually but
um I think that the point of the matter
is that in terms of the the stock of
housing that the council's building
and given the direction of the design
guide I think that you know we are
aiming for B that is very clear and I
think actually when we sift through all
the numbers I think you'll find that
that will ultimately put this these two
districts in a very good position in
terms of the APC ratings of its housing
stock
um because we also have to balance the
need to do that with also building
affordable homes that people can afford
to buy and rent
um so if there is a pragmatic situation
that we ought to need to cope with and
um I'm pretty sure that if we continue
along this trend we will have actually
some of the best housing stock in in
Suffolk
thank you for that
uh
Jen Robinson would like to I just want
to clarify today about where it goes
yeah so the report is not coming back to
Cabinet but of course your comments if
you have concerns or even compliments
your comments can still go to Cabinet
you have that power so any comments or
or matters that you want raised with
cabinet you can take to Cabinet
irrespective that the report is not
coming back to Cabinet as such thank you
for that clarification Council scarf
picture and I particularly welcome that
so I think you know if there is an
opportunity for us to raise anything
where we've had an issue today that that
is to be taken on board
um I think my comment would be generally
about the way that um
presented this year as opposed to
previous years and I would say that I
would like to congratulate officers for
the way that they've actually done it
I like the um
yellow highlighting in the report
because it's very helpful to sift out
what our new actions and what are not
new actions
condensing of those actions where we've
actually took them into business as
usual I think that's been uh extremely
helpful there was a bit of dichotomy
between the slide presentation and the
actual paper presentation which gave
members a little bit
so you tried to work it into I think
it's referred to into that but I think
overall I think a welcome today's
presentation by officers because I think
for classic purposes it's been much
easier for men
constructive comment on it I think
all right cancellation
yeah thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
complement the offices as well I think
it's been a very very good uh
presentation and the work that has gone
into it has been absolutely uh great
there has been difficulties as uh
Carlton's counselor Scarface uh alluded
to
um I would just like to add that
there has been quite a lot of work on
housing our older housing soft
particularly in Sudbury Harmony Talking
roughly at Sudbury
and that has been well looked looked at
and it's taken a few years to get it but
the insulation a new insulation that's
been put in and the areas that have been
improved has certainly uh certainly made
a lot of difference and I will see as
councilor Mathison stated I would like
I'd like to see that carry on and also
coming from a planning point of view we
have had situations where
the Sudbury not a Sudbury the Suffolk
design guide has been commented on on
lots of occasions where we've had to
refuse uh
applications on the basis that the
design wasn't good enough and I think
that's where we should be going from on
that point but well done in the offices
and thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you
councilor Osborne so where do we go with
recommendations motions proposals and so
on
um I think it's fairly clear
if people agree with cancer scarf that
um that we do need to be informing
cabinet but I think councilor Hinton
you've got a comment before we even
on this on this business of when you
look at the recommendations on the
papers where it talks about
where appropriate provide comment uh I
think it's important that we do provide
some comment and I've noted down during
the course of the discussions and a
couple of points here and one of which
was that there should be flexibility in
the housing stock to enable a more more
mobile occupancy EG downsizing
so that it's a housing stock that we put
together is maintains its flexibility we
can't change what we've already got but
we can influence the new stock that
comes along and make sure that it fits
into those and complements those that a
and also the endorse a proactive support
system in times of stress at EG the
current cost of living Rises which has
has been mentioned by the officers I
think is important as well
otherwise it's the most of it is covered
within the document itself which has
said is very comprehensive sometimes as
I said earlier a bit too comprehensive
and it seems to come at the same bit
several times
it's covered several times and not at
all
would would members be happy if we were
then to pass our verbal well obviously
to write out the verbal comments not for
us to appear but to put together the
comments that have been made by members
um and pass them on to perhaps the
portfolio holders and cabinets so that
the portfolio holders can take these
into account and cabinets when they
debate any issues around the
um these strategies that they take them
into account so it is something like
that acceptable counteract people
thank you chairman I think that's very
acceptable but I think we should include
officers as well as cabinet in that I'm
sure the officers have been taking note
of the various comments that have been
been
in regard to the review this morning and
um whilst we all acknowledge that
there's been a pretty comprehensive
document that's been put in front of us
to look at and we very much welcome that
then there are obviously a number of
points that have been raised during the
course of the discussion that I believe
officers have indicated they would take
on board so I think that in the in the
recommendation for the comments back
when
cabinet but we should include officers
as well thank you as well as the
portfolio
so it was Council Caster yeah I agree
with a suggestion a bit earlier
about the need to um when you um
to support families downsizing with um
Financial maybe I think you're alluding
to financial help with the actual move
which
said you know incentive probably
um
you know you say in French is 500 quid
towards the new carpet sort of thing but
it is
the actual organizational you know
you've got to get hold of him you've got
to sort them I probably should get it
absolutely all that sort of thing I
should
physical people help
that they need
um you know and I noticed Council Hinton
actually referred downsizing again so I
think that's certainly something that's
that's shared around the the committee
um that we we do something more than
um perhaps what we're doing at the
moment yeah
yeah that's what I'd quite like to see
somewhere in here attached something
that supports the officers doing what
they it sounds like they want to do with
um the country homes a potential um
downsides of the country homes and
something some form of support like that
I think I I thought that was a really
good line to go down so um I just yeah I
think um your suggestion with how we
attach members comments onto this is a
really good one but I'd like to see
that looked into a bit more I think
that's what
in terms of rather you know Hawks and
do we find out a different use for the
houses or do we actually
put more service into into the places
that have got a lesser or difficult to
let sheltered housing is that what
you're saying um well I wasn't talking
no I was talking more about the um
the downsizing and yeah the support that
you were I'm talking about because um it
is obviously a massive obstruction to
releasing a whole load of bedrooms and
um and capacity within our housing
system so really really important so I'd
like to see
that included
could I could read out my scribbles and
see if at least that may be a start on
uh some some sort of uh proposal that
someone might like to sign up to
um joint overview and security informs
cabinets or
uh
well perhaps not capitalism for informs
uh
well the members members reviewed the
con contents of report Jos 2217
including the appendices and requests
that portfolio holders and officers take
account of verbal comments made by
members of the committee and cabinet
also bear those comments in mind when
debating the refocused delivery plan and
the refreshed joint homes and housing
strategy and the joint homelessness and
rough sleeping strategy
um
members of the committee supported the
Strategic aims of the joint homes and
housing strategy and agree that the
newly focused plan is reflective of the
current challenges facing the housing
sector whilst continuing to deliver the
aims set out in the strategy and ask
portfolio holders and officers to
consider further provision of Financial
and physical support to Residents
wishing to downsize
is that is that okay
is anyone prepared to propose that
but all of the other comments are
wrapped up there will be there will be a
the report will be going on to the
portfolio holders
I mean more or less in the form of the
the minutes of this meeting though we'll
go on to the portfolio holders it will
go on to offices besides just the the
ones who've done such Sterling work this
morning
um uh and and also onto cabinet members
so
those who need those who need the
comments will see the comments
um
and I think it's right to support the
um the strategy uh the work that the
officers have have done in refocusing
the plan
and I think the key thing that has come
out of this or one of the key things
only one but one of the key things is
Islam that there needs to be a look at
how to support people wishing to
downsize
so
if I
so um do you want me to read it out
again or are you content with that
you're happy with that
um Council Castle
side of things but um
it's a lot more complicated than just
going oh retirees want to live in
country homes there's bus services and
um sustainability and that to think
about so um I did originally think that
we we should be um it's quite important
to be looking at those country homes for
people alongside the downsizing I think
that will probably come with that
because it's it's quite obvious and it
was it was brought up by officers in the
first place yeah so yeah I
going to propose
yes certainly
can I just ask you please to add Maybe
in Brackets or
that the downsizing shouldn't only refer
to older people that it should be to all
demographics please
um because I don't want it to be simply
answered by the report that coming up
regarding older people I want it to be
looked at more broadly than that please
so it's fit Financial physical supports
are all residents who wish down size
yeah
counselor Henson if I could put a
comment on there and I I endorse what
you're what you're saying there but if
you look within the report it talks
about both baber and mid-suffica
classified as predominantly rural areas
surprise surprise although deprivation
levels are low compared with national
levels across across Suffolk 28 of those
identified as income deprived live in
rural areas
living in a very rural area is widely
considered to cost households on average
of 20 more than a similar household
living in an urban area so all
households having the opportunity to
downsize to save costs and
very important and also added addition
that Council Brandon's put forward thank
you very much
so do I have a proposal and a second
councilor Grandin and councilor Castle
thank you very much
right so Council counselor
your your counselor sorry who's the
loss now who has
proposed Bradley II right okay councilor
Mathison is proposing councilor granted
is seconding
and
councilman
councilman's happy with us against the
brownie point so
so
um
with that we'll take this to the
electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that is nine votes for
status unanimous
thank you very much
um can we then move on to
forthcoming decisions list has anyone
got any comments they want to make
um
thank you and the decisions list is for
noting
the action tracker item 9jos 2219 the
overview security Committee Action
tracker
um
having made the comment myself that we
will try to put more into that action
tracker for the next meeting
um are you happy to just note the action
tracker as it stands for the time B
yeah thank you very much
favor members
yours over your scrutiny work plan
are you content to note that bearing in
mind that your chair and vice chair will
be
discussing that again next week
I've got nods all around so that is
noted
mid-suffolk members
are we all happy
or content
to note
the mid-sufficient work plan
thank you very much uh yes so thank you
the work plan is for Noti that concludes
the business of this meeting and the
time is 11 25. thank you very much
everybody thank you very much officers
it's been a very full morning uh you've
done yeah you've done Sterling work and
thank you for all the responses you gave
and for the presentation too thank you